so did you get finalized did you have
like I had like went out to see like
five chicks two of them are potentials
now it's one or two or
um it wasn't it wasn't five would have
been like I would have probably died
from excitement um
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys and
today we have Walter Hong here whatever
what's up
you ever go on your uh love Escapade in
Korea and you find your oh yeah I did
because it wasn't asking
yeah I went to Korea
um you know I do gotta say no I didn't
get to do any of that
um really oh wait to catch her up um so
he's a sec he's a sex tourist and he
goes to different countries you're a sex
tourist yeah haven't you ever heard of
those it's very new and very in today
sex tourism usually they go to
Philippines
um and I think uh like Thailand it's
affordable um but yeah and like they
have I don't know if they still have had
this but I remember like in the 90s they
would have these packages like sex tour
packages what are you being serious this
toy is totally serious they go to the
Philippines they go to Thailand and you
just go and you whoremonger oh my God
describe a whoremonger's normal day you
start today with electrolytes I know how
the night ends you gotta stay hydrated
probably
electrolytes I imagine some of these
like salt tablets if you're if you're a
whoremonger to me you're probably a
professional so they probably Morning
Noon night
they're probably for [__] yeah do you
think there's a lot of caffeine involved
I got a lot of naps involved no he went
he went to go find a a mate yeah I went
to go find to permanently to yeah
fertilize eggs we're a wife mongering
yeah I was wife hungry I do gotta say
you know the difference with uh dating
with the intent to just date versus
dating with the intent to get married is
vastly different and I didn't really you
weren't ready for it yeah it was weird
what's the difference one sex tourism
yeah what what's one sex tourism love
tourism the other one is you have to
pretend you don't want sex right away
you know
um no but that never works I've been
doing that my whole life it was just
very
um
the question I don't think quite but
like the conversations are different you
know because
um it's not just like oh hey let's just
like hang out and also because of the
distance there is no like um oh I'll see
you next week so you're trying to figure
out a lot of things
um in a week or two yeah you know a week
or like even in one date you're trying
to find out a lot of things because
you're trying to figure out is this
worth another date and so you're taking
things a lot more seriously like when
where normally you would even think
about it is it does it feel like there's
way more pressure there is a lot more
pressure on the date and so um so for
example like let's say you're eating
with someone right and then like she
doesn't I don't know like wipe her mouth
just for example yeah disgusting and
then yeah like if you're just dating
you're like whatever no big deal but
then when you're looking at this you're
like is she a dirty person yeah like is
her place but everything is magnified
yeah everything's magnified yeah yeah
you're speed assessing every trade yeah
and you don't want to because you feel
so judgmental but at the same time you
have no choice yeah you have no choice
I'm only there for two weeks it's not
like you know I'm gonna be like oh hey
like
um I'll see you a week from now and then
you know I'll look at other things no
like I have to see like is she worth
like for him you know and I'm sure she's
thinking am I worth going out with again
do you think that puts people in a place
where they are
putting their best foot forward and now
they're perceived as this person and
they're like oh great this is the person
that I want to continue dating and they
actually are not that person at all
because there's so much pressure in
those first interactions yeah so like
you know with like regular dating like
with dating you're just a date that
happens right like you put your best
foot forward I feel like this was like
your best bestest foot forward and then
there's just more intense scrutiny and I
know this might be more yeah but that's
not always going to be the standard
throughout oh yeah you know what I mean
you're not upholding that and that's the
other thing you have to navigate through
is like is am I putting a like a front
where I'm like being opposite of how I
really am and is she doing the same
thing and were you wearing this shirt I
you know what I was not but I was
wearing my Rams boxers okay so like I
might have been faking it there I know
yeah so it's definitely
because I didn't expect like dating to
be different
um for the antenna getting married
um when I when I realized that it was
different I was like okay this is just
there's so much thinking involved and I
already think a lot to begin with and
then so after Jay there's even more
thinking I'm playing back what happened
and just like okay does it what does
this mean does this mean like she's
gonna be like this later or you know
like what's going on and I'm like whoa
you gotta stop like just try to relax
and try to like pace yourself do you
feel like when you date like that it's
hard for you guys to just kind of be in
the moment sometimes yeah it's very
because there was no time to just like
hang out yeah you know like it's a
makeout it's like every question is like
some crazy you guys might as well as
just exchange pieces of paper and just
be like oh these boxes checked yep yep
okay well now we can at least start
having a conversation a little bit which
is like a dating app though right I mean
everybody has their own preferences hey
what's your best pitch though like what
do you start with for dating app or no
just when you're when you're when you go
to a date what's your open
do you have do you have like like a
routine but like you know because I'm so
bad at the whole dating thing that I
can't even have like a routine because
I'd be like oh like that didn't work so
then let's try why do you think you're
bad because I'm still single that's not
true I mean well it's dating right it's
not I'm not bad at relationships yeah oh
yeah the relationship part
um but you're pretty excited I think I'm
great but then she may not but I think
I'm rude but you know it's just getting
there yeah and did you did you actually
meet somebody that you felt was like
kind of hitting it for you yeah like
so the funny thing is is that because
the intent is different like I had to
also shift what I was looking for not in
the sense of like what kind of woman I
want to be with not that but just in
terms of like when you're just dating
the date you're just like oh yeah cool
you know it's just casual whatever but
this
um once I had to call myself down then I
started to kind of like let the when the
dust let the dust settle it was like
okay this is kind of cool
um like this part of her is kind of cool
yeah let's see so there's a girl that I
did go out a handful of times with oh
cool um yeah so that was cool
um as far as like do I think we're gonna
get married or is it like I had to
really just bring all that down despite
the fact that I'm like you know
scrutinizing every little thing what's
what's the good traits that you like
about it that you found she's really
sweet and warm
you know yeah that's like that's really
nice like a little Cinnabon yeah you
know I haven't tasted it but I know
that's good you haven't tasted yeah I
don't know it was that sweet what kind
of stuff did you guys do that's the
thing is we only went to like dinner we
did go to the one like sort of
activities they're the they have a
seafood market in in Korea yeah that
there's just tanks everywhere and you
walk around you tour the area it's fresh
catch every day and you just pick like
what you want so like if there's like
Abalone it smells like food like oh I
want that you know if there's like fresh
Ketch of tuna that day they'll have it
on display that's so Asian isn't it
tight and then there's things that
you've never seen it's so live in the
ocean and you're just like I want that
so it's kind of like a cooler aquarium
date totally and but then you get you
get to sample it and then and then it's
and then whatever place you go to they
it's connected to a restaurant and
they'll prepare it for you like so it's
like sashimi we had live octopus
um so yeah the plates like obviously all
crawling with octopus tentacles oh can I
give you a knife yeah I don't know if
it'll work or not yeah yeah but because
she's under the same
like pretense she's trying to get
married too right yeah yeah what if you
guys like got an Airbnb and had like a
husband and wife all day role-playing so
like you come home from like you come
home from work or whatever like and like
actually try to live kind of like a test
drive like does this work out the first
20 minutes you called her a [__]
[Laughter]
for more like hug me to calm me down
what the hell why did you sign the
divorce papers
I come out with bruises you know I know
a friend of mine suggested you should
just you guys should go on a trip
together because the case like when you
go on a trip you really see how people
are that's a that's a fast track yeah
you're right it's a fast track expensive
Fast Track or like a road trip too yeah
like a road trip and Korea's Korea's
road trips are pretty famous because
they have their rest stops have
um food like specific Foods so it's not
like here where our road stops you know
it's a metal toilet yeah what the
heckies dude uh but like yeah definitely
though um I think the trip is like it's
a good idea but the distance also makes
it you know difficult too are you guys
still talking yeah we're still talking
oh what's up
[Applause]
your guys's reach reaches out to Korea
yeah so I did a show in Korea do you
hate us in Korea too
just the guy just the guy wearing Shades
but no it's uh oh uh in Korea did a show
and obviously in English and there was a
couple white man Korean woman and I made
fun of them I feel made fun of her for
being a race Trader you have to oh
you're so good after the show they came
up to me and then the guy goes do you
know why we're here and I go no and I
when people ask that I don't know how to
respond because I don't want to be mean
because I'm thankful that they came so
oh no but instead I'm going how am I
supposed to know why you came I don't
know
and the thing is they're probably
watching this right now but he goes my
wife is a big fan of just kidding news
she's seen you on there and then when
she saw that you're gonna be in Korea
she's like we have to go so thank you
guys for coming
um race Trader it was awesome
why does it not surprise me we have race
Trader fans
but yeah no I wanted to like I was like
when they when they told me that I was
excited to tell you guys that's dope
dude yeah that's tight so yeah she came
just because she saw me on here and so I
was like oh that's awesome one of our
recent guests names Jared he's a
bodybuilder and he likes specifically
Southeast Asian women and he has a
specific term that his friends and him
call they call him Jerry's I always said
Jerry over there and he said after he
did this show he got a DM from a
Peruvian chick and she said can I be
your Jerry too dang wow he's gonna knock
it out nasty
[Laughter]
wow so what's the next step is it are
you gonna go back again and hang out
with that was she gonna come here you're
gonna you're gonna bring that Walter
back down yeah
we broached the subject while I was out
there about like you know like me going
back there or her coming out here but we
haven't like actually like discussed it
discussed it
I did kind of like did a a simple quick
search in private mode on my ISP so I
don't get tagged especially for plane
tickets but in June the cheapest flight
on a hybrid Airline which is if you
don't know what that is it's a half
budget half regular Airline is twenty
three hundred dollar round trip
and then the regular Airlines they're
like 2800 it's a lot and then I found
out it's because in June is when
vacation starts for like everybody so
they're all flying back and forth yeah
it's crazy God damn please man I get you
he's a [__] and then my friend
that's in Taiwan it was never been like
she told me it's 1400 one way and I go
well because you did one way yeah
because business class used to be like
three G's yes but now it's 2 800. no
business class to Korea on my flight
when I went was five grand oh God you
know how you can do the upgrade whether
you buy a regular seat and you upgrade
with points the points were like a like
it was like a crazy amount and I was
like what is going on and then they told
me oh the flight costs like five
thousand dollars I'm gonna burn my
passport I'm not going anywhere bro
[Laughter]
do you think it's hide in Nevada yeah
that's true so what's the next move then
um for me right now personally it's just
to keep talking yeah and then like see
each other again you know but you know I
do I am intrigued by the whole arranged
marriage thing
like uh or arranged marriage is light
because like it like you know obviously
our divorce rate here is like over a
little over 50 yeah arranged marriage
divorce rates are a lot lower and I I
think and I broke this down because I
have a bachelor's degree in Psychology
from the University of Southern
California I also graduated Sunny Hills
it sounds more incredible when you talk
to these questions right and it was
deservable
um so like when that's all you're acting
and I wrestled I wrestled so uh uh but
like when you look at our relationships
the uh we date for like three four years
and then we get married the first step
after we're married isn't compromised
the first step is I gotta get what I
want and you're gonna get what you want
so we're gonna be adversarial you know a
lot of times you hear people get married
um they're married friends to tell them
dude you cannot lose the first fight
because then that sets the tone for the
rest of your marriage this sounds like
the worst friends in the world I know I
know they sound like they're not married
they sound like they got a lot of
difference what's their track record
exactly
but like when you look at arranged
marriages their first step is compromise
because they don't really know each
other well yeah so they're all kind of
like they're like I don't I don't want
to like step on anyone's toes so the
first step is compromise and so I think
that's one of the keys to have them La
the relationships last longer so I'm
intrigued by the whole don't you think a
lot of it is cultural though like the
cultural context of like why they are so
in on like I'm all in on uh arranged
marriages because it's so much pressure
from parents and that's just how they
live it could yeah it could be it could
be Americans don't like you still get
like dowries and [__] for that though
right yeah that's true yeah yeah I'm
intrigued by the whole thing so like if
you're trying to create alliances it's
harder to divorce isn't it probably you
know well nowadays though because of
Western influence it's it's easier like
in Korea for instance back back in the
day divorce was just unheard of but if
you did get divorced the children would
go with the dad
they wouldn't go with the mom because
the dad is the money order and so it's
just and culturally it's just different
but now they're starting to like have
the mothers take the mothers take the
kids but but a lot of Western
influencers seeing the beauty of divorce
now yeah
to be honest that's yeah that's what you
know what it is because you know like in
when there's no divorce a lot of these
like Psychopathic or sociopathic
husbands think they can do whatever they
want with their to their wives That's
the flip side yeah that's like the bad
side is that a good thing for you like
like I can be a psycho that'd be kind of
cool oh
spider you want
you want to think about that
it's marriage that could be a real dude
dude like if you saw you if you saw your
woman one day bring home like a bunch of
lime yeah wouldn't that they can pause
yeah dude I'm
squeezing my fist I'm getting ready
but yeah no I I like and I'm not saying
I'm a proponent of arranged marriages
but for me personally I'm intrigued by
the whole the whole thing of like how do
we get you in a range of marriage then
how would we said well in the situation
I'm in now let's just say for example
asking us to arrange one for you yeah
yeah let's just say for example we got
married
like sooner rather than later like let's
say within a year it's almost like to me
it's a pre-arranged light because we
don't we don't have the the um the uh
like let's see like the that's what I'm
looking for the my opportunity but like
we don't have the um
chance to kind of get to know each other
for three four five years and then get
married but like if we only knew each
other for a few months and then we got
married
it's kind of like to me like it's like
an arrange marriage light that's what I
like about arranged marriages I feel
like it's um not the arranged marriage
but I feel like the the mindset that
you're in it's teamwork yeah the mindset
is we have to make this work as a team
and regardless if it's a ranged marriage
or like two people stuck on an island
that then like they need to survive yeah
like you don't have time to like I'm
gonna [__] bicker it's like dude we
gotta that's true you built a shelter I
go [__] go kill the [__] squirrel
or something I gotta make dinner and
then we so it's almost that like that
mindset that I think
ends up making it work because my
grandparents were arranged and they're
the most loving couple that I've seen
but that's like when they're 70 or 80.
yeah and I'm sure they had really tough
times in the beginning but I think
having that mindset of like no matter
what because that's where it starts from
yeah right it's like we got to make this
work no matter what because I think some
people when they do get married once
they get married they realize like oh
wait I have to make sacrifices that I
don't want to make like what the [__] or
even or even like the day one going like
if this isn't working on on the divorce
so like you already have that option and
it's so but when you threaten divorce
when you throw that card on the table
you get whatever you want
it's a [__] Ace in the Hole for both
sides and I get to eat whatever I want
for dinner when I throw it out you're
both I just stalemate you're like [__]
we're both throwing down the card it's
like I don't want Oreo pins I want full
fat double stuff Oreos
yeah dude because because I hear my like
stories of my dad like he would throw
like he got papers sent to my mom's work
and then um my dad's like my dad's like
expensive your mom's so [__] stupid
she [__] divorced me you know like
always as a kid growing up I would like
you know hear both sides and my mom
would like well yeah he sent the papers
to my work and then I was like Dad mom
said you set the papers through her work
he goes yeah but she's not supposed to
[__] sign it yeah yeah I'm like
yeah that's the power play and I go mom
we're not supposed to sign it he comes
home of course I'm gonna sign it and I'm
like of course you're gonna sign it
so they're like my parents were like the
direct like don't do this yeah yeah and
then my grandparents were kind of like
Meyer do you know the arrangement that
your grandparents had it was just more
it was I think like as it went from
[__] Tang Dynasty or whatever it just
gets looser and looser and looser so for
them it was they were like a neighboring
like I don't know like neighborhoods or
whatever and it's like oh that guy's
kind of cool are they are a family
similar status uh that one is like you
know it's like a bunch of like wives
tales like oh that's the uh that's like
the older sister or the younger sister
so that means they're more like
nurturing and oh yeah that's the middle
child that means that guy's very
industrious so it's like just a lot of
like wives tales and they're like this
will work and then they pitched each
other and I don't know if they had like
an official Dowry or whatever
um so it wasn't like two Kung Fu Clans
coming together to make one thing to
make one big Kung fuent they're playing
mantis to like create a new animal yeah
I don't know yeah that's advantageous
for the culture right so did you get
finalized did you have like I had like
went out to see like five chicks two of
them are potentials now it's one or two
or no it wasn't it wasn't five would
have been like I would have probably
died from excitement um
that's a lot of dates though yeah you
know um it's a lot of conversation but
yeah no there there was uh situation
yeah there was like a let's see one and
a half dude you're totally burning him
he told the girl that she was the only
one yikes no no no no no
you race Trader
no I'm just here to see you
babe
don't listen to my American ways
he has language issues
um his English isn't so good we not
speak Korean
um no but I think definitely like I love
your explanation of the the arranged
marriage thing where it's not the
arranged marriage that you support it's
just like the thought process season
yeah thank you
foreign